die korona app hat ein update bekommen
das den nutzer nun nach und nach zur
verfügung gestellt wird es sind zwei
neue funktionen von denen sich die
macher und die politik mehr sicherheit
und kontrolle versprechen
zum einen wird die app nun über
deutschlands grenzen hinaus in etlichen
weiteren europäischen ländern
funktionieren
zum anderen können positiv getestete
nutzer freiwillig eine art tagebuch über
ihre symptome führen das soll helfen zu
bestimmen wie infektiös die betroffenen
sind und so die warnungen der app
genauer machen etwa 20 millionen mal
wurde die anwendung bereits in
deutschland runtergeladen
experten gehen von einer aktiven nutzung
von etwa 16 millionen menschen aus
bekommt man eine nachricht über einen
kontakt mit einem corona positiv
getesteten menschen sagt die app was die
nächsten schritte sind und tatsächlich
berichten immer mehr nutzer über
gestiegene warnungen das bestätigt auch
kanzleramtsminister helge braun
die app ist kein werkzeug zur bekämpfung
der pandemie
das wissen auch die macher trotzdem
hoffen sie diese dadurch besser
beherrschen zu können
[Musik]
und bei mir im studio ist jetzt zum als
pavel von unserem ressort leben und
wissen
du kannst uns genauer erklären welche
beiden funktionen es jetzt gibt und vor
allem bastians bringen genau die krone
waren hat das gestern ein neues update
bekommen damit kamen zwei neue
funktionen für die app einer davon ist
ein symptome tagebuch das ist eine
funktion die die meisten hoffentlich nie
zu gesicht bekommen denn dass es für
alle infizierten die sich innerhalb der
app als infiziert gemeldet haben dort
können sie dann ihre symptome eintragen
also wann habe ich zum beispiel wussten
bekommen wann habe ich viel bekommen und
diese daten sollen dabei helfen die
risikobewertung zu verbessern
die andere funktion ist das nun das
grundgerüst dafür gelegt wurde dass die
korona web auch in europa funktioniert
und auch mit anderen krone war apps in
europa kommunizieren kann
und also nicht nur auf deutschland
beschränkt ist du weißt du sagst das
grundgerüst wurde gelegt ich schließe
daraus sie funktioniert also noch nicht
in ganz europa kannst du denn irgendwie
ein kreisen wo sie funktioniert wo ich
sie wirklich sinnvoll anwenden kann oder
steckt das wirklich noch in den
kinderschuhen nähe in den kinderschuhen
steckt es nicht mehr jetzt mit dem
update funktioniert es in irland und
italien und in deutschland das heißt die
liste ist jetzt noch sehr klein aber im
laufe dieses und nächsten monats sollen
insgesamt elf länder zu diesem verbund
dazu kommen unter anderem tschechien
polen österreich die niederlande und
auch dänemark und so viele nachbarländer
von deutschland kommen auch mit dazu und
langfristig könnten das auch noch mehr
werden
hintergrund ist diese apps benutzen alle
ein ähnliches technisches grundgerüst
und können so auch miteinander verknüpft
werden
dafür wurde jetzt ein eigener
europäischer server aufgesetzt der dafür
genutzt wird und es kommen immer mehr
apps dann dazu dies sind deine bewertung
dieser app du bist ja auch technisch
durchaus versiert heißt du das gefühl
die bringt wirklich was oder würdest du
eher herrn söder zustimmen der sagte das
ist ein zahnloser tiger nun bei der
krone one app ist natürlich ein bisschen
die krux mit dem datenschutz wir wissen
immer gar nicht so genau wie viele leute
haben jetzt wirklich die warnung
bekommen und wie viele reagieren auch
darauf und die informationen die die
menschen bekommen sind natürlich auch
sehr eingeschränkt denn sie wissen
wirklich nur
ich hatte kontakt aber nicht wann und wo
das heißt es kommt ganz stark darauf an
wie viele leute benutzen die app und da
müssen wir sagen letzte zahlen waren das
ungefähr 10.000 leute ihre infektion
eingetragen haben
das ist im vergleich zu den aktuellen
neue fraktions zahlen relativ wenig das
heißt moment würde ich sagen so viel
bringt sie noch nicht aber es kommt ganz
stark darauf an wie viele leute sich
wirklich dazu entscheiden diese einfach
zu benutzen und auf die ratschläge zu
hören die ihnen diese app auch stecken
also je mehr desto besser thermal spa
wohl aus unserem ressort leben und
wissen danke für deinen besuch im studio
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren